how much space do we need to live in
Apple John works in theater in Berlin
and he thinks we don't need much he
lives in what's known as a tiny house on
wheels the cool thing is that as soon as
you enter you're in the bedroom the
living room the kitchen and the hallway
at the same time all the lights are
gonna it's designed so that everything
can be folded up and unfolded when it's
needed you've got everything you need
it measures just 9 square meters but
there's a surprising amount of storage
space built into the walls and floor so
this is done despise here's one example
when you're finished in the kitchen you
have to put away the stove of grilling
threaten owned the stuff even that's the
basic concept it takes a lot of getting
used to but in the long run it's a
really functional system in every way a
tiny house wouldn't suit luxury lovers
who like to surround themselves with
lots of possessions but it's a living
space alternative that appeals to a
growing number of people
in cities that need more affordable
housing tiny houses are an interesting
option cabins like these could be
installed on land that's not being used
or even on the roofs of existing
buildings affordable housing is growing
ever scarce er in more and more cities
one Berlin entrepreneur has a vision of
a city above a city hope to endure stop
thinking abut infrastructure extends
right up to the roof of a house that's
where we want to hook up our cabins in
cities infrastructure is everywhere up
here on the roof I've got a power
connection that connects me to the grid
and it could also work with water and
sewage with 20 square meters these
cabins would be relatively spacious for
the time being they only exist as a
mock-up but the first prototype is
currently under construction it will
cost 50,000 euros the startup already
has some potential customers lined up
and demonstrating the concept and the
product allow us to make use of spaces
that aren't suited to conventional
housing or have simply gone unnoticed we
would like to use any space that is
large enough to accommodate a mini house
we have our sights set on any leftover
space where a mini house could be placed
1u housing solutions have to be found
just one example berlin needs 17,000 new
apartments every year